en puerto príncipe el pasado 10 de
diciembre miles de personas expresaron
su rabia y su angustia y denunciaron la
inacción del estado frente al alto costo
de la vida y la violencia de las bandas
nos vamos a coordinar con los otros
sectores sociales para movilizarnos
contra las bandas la inseguridad y el
alza de los precios
desde diciembre la inseguridad ha
empeorado tiroteos asesinatos secuestros
violaciones los grupos mafiosos reclutan
fácilmente entre los más desamparados
según las cifras del 2020 del banco
mundial el 15 por ciento de la población
está desempleada en un país de 11
millones de habitantes
las bandas controlan gran parte de la
capital haitiana y las principales rutas
hacia el sur y hacia el norte del país
que llevan a esta república dominicana
la policía mal pagada y mal armada
prácticamente no reacciona lo que otorga
a este jefe mafioso un sentimiento de
impunidad total
prueben que secuestramos gente y el
pondré las armas y me entregaré a la
justicia
instamos al primer ministro ariel en rey
a renunciar un comentario en relación al
asesinato del presidente lleven el móvil
de 2021 el magnicidio frágil hizo un
estado que ya afrontaba grandes
dificultades como combatir la pobreza o
reconstruir las infraestructuras
devastadas por catástrofes naturales
según la onu el 46% de la población de
haití necesitará ayuda humanitaria este
año múltiples crisis que las autoridades
usan para justificar el aplazamiento
indefinido de las elecciones
presidenciales y legislativas agendadas
originalmente para principios de este